republicans subject attorney general
merrick garland to a rough day in the
senate joe biden heads to an
international climate summit and the
state department says people of no
gender can now get their passports
stamped x i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressivevpn why haven't you gotten a
vpn yet visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first
let's say that you were just minding
your own business and one day you got
the news that a house had fallen out of
the sky and crushed your sister and that
the person who had occupied that house
and then stolen the shoes of said sister
and begun a journey to somehow go to the
center of a civilization where the head
of the civilization was your sworn enemy
so you go after her you capture her
finally you're about to take your
revenge and she hits you with a bucket
of water well as you're melting you
might think to yourself
man i really should have listened to
shapiro and gotten life insurance via
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare well you could say 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save 1300 or
more per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies the
licensed experts at policy genius work
for you not the insurance companies so
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of services earn
policy genius thousands of five star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor getting started is simple
go to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
compare personalized quotes find your
best price policy genius handles the
rest head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
very nice to get it right alrighty so
yesterday attorney general mayor garland
remember this was supposed to be a legal
mind for the ages and he wasn't just
some sort of political hack who
did the law no he was not an eric holder
type he was going to be a non-partisan
unifying figure that's why he was picked
remember some of the alternatives that
joe biden had been looking at were far
more radical publicly facing
than merrick garland was for attorney
general and they've been talking about
doug jones from alabama as the attorney
general of the united states they've
been talking about bringing back some of
the obama holdovers instead joe biden
picked merrick garland specifically
because merrick garland was supposed to
not be a political hack widely respected
almost made the supreme court right
instead it turns out that pretty much
every
left-minded
judicial appointee if given the power of
the attorney general would turn into
merrick garland this seems to be the
case so merrick garland has been a very
highly political attorney general and he
was called in front of the senate
yesterday to talk about how the doj was
targeting parents because remember the
doj put out an entire memo talking about
how they were going to essentially sick
the fbi on parents who had questions
about how school boards were running and
they did so at the behest of a national
school boards association which had
claimed that there was a massive uptick
in violence against school boards
without actually demonstrating that that
was in fact the case
so yesterday merrick island was called
to the hill
and he was asked questions about this
because when the federal government is
called upon by an outside source to
start investigating violence and then on
the basis of no evidence starts to do
that this could have a pretty
significant chilling effect on people
who might want to get involved in say
their local school board if you found
out that the fbi and doj were suddenly
targeting your point of view and giving
you a little bit of extra scrutiny
because they had been told to by your
political opponents might that not be
somewhat chilling so merrick garland was
specifically asked about the fact that
if this really was a pressing law
enforcement issue that required the
intervention of the doj could he name
any specific act of violence that had
led to this large-scale announcement
from the doj here was merrick garland
saying well not so much
best of my recollection i said that the
impetus for the letter
from my memorandum was that letter and
also uh reports
of this kind of activity what reports
i said again that at the time that they
were news reports
that had
been published and i think that uh some
of the other senators here have
described some of those news reports and
we've certainly seen subsequently more
news reports and more statements by
board members of threats to kill them
okay so threats of violence okay but but
when cotton asked him specifically about
the memo that the doj put out which
included quote violence threats of
violence as well as harassment and
intimidation garland had no response
because harassment and intimidation are
not quite the same thing as threats of
violence
because it turns out that if somebody
disagrees with you at a school board
meeting that could be considered quote
unquote harassment or intimidation this
is something mike lee pointed out
okay so merrick garland then
admitted that the original letter that
that caused the doj to start looking
into parents did not include acts of
violence in the letter
you didn't investigate the incidents in
the letter did you no
this is the first step this is an
assessment step that comes before
investigations
before you issued your memo you didn't
investigate the incident remember the
memo isn't intended to begin assessments
it is intended and in fact most of the
instance
in the letter were did not involve
threats of violence did they i think
that's correct most of them did not and
they would not be covered by either
federal or state law i agree with that
and they would be protected by the first
amendment
okay so then the question is if you did
not have a pressing need to do this why
did you do this and the answer of course
is that this served the left-leaning
agenda suggesting that school boards
everywhere are doing a wonderful job and
parents who have questions about school
boards are doing a terrible job this led
tom cotton to rip into america garland
telling him he probably should just
resign his job
do you apologize to scott smith and his
15 year old daughter judge
senator anyone whose
child was raped as
is the most horrific crime i can imagine
and is certainly entitled and protected
by the first amendment to protest to
their school board about that but he was
cited by the school board association
that's fine he's a domestic terrorist
which we now know that letter and those
reports were the basis for your
business this is that's wrong judges is
shameful
this testimony your directive your
performance is shameful that's not thank
god you are not on the supreme court you
should resign in disgrace judge
okay and of course merrick garland was
very upset because he said well it's not
really the nsba letter that caused us to
do all this it was just kind of the nsba
letter that caused us to do all this
josh haley got in on the act as well the
senator from missouri he he said that
you guys are talking about using the
language of domestic terrorism via the
nsba to apply to parents what are you
doing here
several of my democrat colleagues have
today just today in this hearing
multiple times have compared parents who
show up at school board meetings like mr
smith here have compared them to
criminal rioters you think that's right
you think that a parent who shows up at
a school board meeting who has a
complaint who wants to voice that
complaint and maybe she doesn't use
exactly the right grammar you think
they're akin to criminal writers do you
agree with that i do not and i do not
remember any senator here compare making
that comparison oh really these people
are just like the folks who came here on
january 6 and in the riot at the capitol
i don't think it was they were referring
to the picture that you're showing there
so then who exactly were they referring
to so here is the thing when it comes to
the application of law via the attorney
general's office when it comes to the
doj the doj has to be
a somewhat
honorable institution bill barr got an
enormous amount of flack when he was
attorney general because the idea from
the left is that he was doing the
bidding of donald trump routinely that
was not true we know many occasions
where bill barr was directly at odds
with donald trump donald trump for
example wanted bill barr he wanted jeff
sessions to investigate hillary clinton
they didn't do that he wanted bill barr
to start initiating investigations of
the election and bill barr wouldn't do
that like this sort of stuff happened
all the time under donald trump can
anyone name a single time where a
democratic president has gone to his a.g
and said i'd like to do x and the ag
said no
see this is the dirty little secret
about the the way that politics work at
the presidential level pretty frequently
when there's a republican president and
he says something untoward the people
around him say you're not allowed to do
that this happened with trump all the
time half of the things that trump
suggested on twitter were then walked
back by his own administration and
people around him said we won't
implement that and then trump just
dropped it but when joe biden says jump
the people around him say how high and
this has some pretty deleterious effects
on americans lives
and to take just another example it is
merrick garland who's been spending his
days cracking down on police departments
around the country while simultaneously
the crime rate's been going up
murder rates have spiked in nearly every
major american city but it was merrick
garland who decided very early on that
he was going to rescind the trump
administration's policies with regard to
consent decrees with regard to local
police departments
it was all the way back in april
that cnbc reported that merrick garland
had rescinded trump-era limits on
consent decrees which the doj had used
to enforce reforms in police departments
accused of widespread misconduct
garland said he would return to the
traditional process in place before
trump's administration imposed sharp
restrictions on the tool garland said in
a memo together we will continue the
department's legacy of promoting the
rule of law protecting the public
working collaboratively with state and
local governmental entities to meet
those ends that is not what consent
decrees historically have been under
democratic administrations consent
decrees have been a way to force local
police departments to tell cops not to
do things right these consent decrees
have largely been based on bad evidence
this is certainly the case with the
seattle consent decree under the obama
administration it's been a way to to
cram down particular
diversity-laden viewpoints that have
nothing to do with the reality of
policing
how the law is enforced matters an awful
lot
and this also happens to be the case i
mean merrick garland got rigged over the
coals yesterday for having greenlit a
settlement
with fb former fbi acting director
andrew mccabe you'll remember that andy
mccabe was fired because an inspector
general found that annie mccabe had lied
in testimony like he had lied to the fbi
and he leaked out information that he
was not cleared to leak
and that's according to james comey
and now the justice department agreed to
pay mccabe and his attorneys over 700
during a senate judiciary committee
oversight hearing senator chuck grassley
expressed outrage over the settlement
calling the move quote beyond incredible
noting that a doj inspector general
review found mccabe to be lying to
investigators on seven separate
occasions
garland's answer quote the mccabe
settlement was a recommendation of the
career lawyers litigating that case
based on their prospects of success in
the case
garland said it involved to claim that
he was not given the amount of time
necessary to respond to allegations the
litigators concluded they needed to
settle the case because of the
likelihood of loss on the merits of the
claim
do you think that on principle if mccabe
had been a strong democrat that that
would have been anything that the doj
decided to settle out
what do you think
and once the doj becomes an overtly
political tool which it is under merit
garland people start to lose trust in
the institutions and again this this
didn't start with him janet reno was a
tool of the clinton administration going
all the way back
but it is worthy of note that this
administration which pledged to be a
bipartisan unifying administration
is basically the soft face of
authoritarianism they're constantly
doing authoritarian things via powers
delegated to them by effectless and
incompetent congress over the course of
decades
and they're just doing what they will
with it
and it's really really ugly okay
meanwhile joe biden is headed overseas
to a climate summit
it's very important according to joe
biden that he goes to this climate
change summit in fact he had built his
entire we're going to make a deal
routine
around going to this climate summit as
though anyone in america cared island in
america was like you know what we need a
budget deal we need to spend trillions
of dollars so joe biden can go to europe
to glasgow and talk with the
international community about climate
change no one in america cares about
that that was their false deadline that
they had set well they didn't hit that
false deadline we'll get to that in just
one moment first let us talk about your
safety and security at home with my ring
alarm security system i am much more at
ease when i'm on the road or away from
home my ring alarm equals peace of mind
protect your home with ring alarm the
same way that i do ring alarm is a
powerful affordable whole home security
system you can easily install yourself
it works seamlessly with other ring
products in one simple app for a special
offer go to ring.com it's the perfect
way to start your ring experience keep
an eye on every corner of your house
with indoor and outdoor cams see what's
happening directly from your phone so
when i'm out of town i like to check
what's going on on my property i
literally know every time the front door
opens thanks to my ring alarm security
system
i also know where my kids are at all
times because let's be frank about this
my kids are wild there are three of them
and they're constantly running all over
the house sometimes i lose track of one
it's like uh-oh where'd the baby go and
then you pull up that ring alarm app and
i know exactly where she is and she's
very squishy protect your home anytime
from anywhere with ring alarm go to
ring.com ben for a special offer on a
ring alarm security kit today you can
build a system right for your home have
it up and running in just minutes that's
ring.com
again ring.com
alrighty so joe biden is headed overseas
to this un global climate summit ooh
we should definitely formulate our
policy around what kenya thinks about
climate change really important to find
out what the swedes think about climate
change frankly if greta tunberg is
disappointed in me i'm willing to pay
trillions of dollars just to prevent
that because if this now adult i can
make fun of person
stares at me angrily and tells me that
as an adult she's disappointed in me
i know that that sears me down to my
soul
it sears me to the point where i am
perfectly willing to allow joe biden to
spend trillions of dollars we don't have
inflate the economy and completely
dissuade people from going back to work
in order that greta twinburg sleeps
better at night
on her yacht like it's very uh
very important to me
so according to cbs news we have now
reached every time it's it's it's funny
i'm not sure how many turning points
there can be before you're just all the
way around in a circle but they keep
talking about how every climate summit
is going to be a turning point
here is the thing gang most global
warming is already baked into the cake
the reality is that any measure that
that dramatically harms the global
economy on behalf of lowering carbon
emissions is a fool's errand you are
much better off taking some of that
potential gain and using it on
mitigation efforts and adaptation
efforts rather than attempting to
completely remake the world economy to
stop carbon emissions altogether
considering a huge percentage of the
world's population still lives in abject
poverty burning dung for fuel
carbon emissions are not the the
specific problem in the long run the
specific problem is how human beings
deal with carbon emissions the earth is
not going to boil not all human life is
going to die all the catastrophic
nonsense about how billions of people
are going to be living in in basically a
mad max universe if global warming
continues it's silly it's not true
technology has improved the united
states for example our emissions have
leveled off china's are not going to
level off china's going to continue to
emit at high rates developing countries
are going to continue to emit at high
rates and by the way if you wanted them
to stop emitting at those high rates
you'd have to pay them trillions of
dollars they are openly saying this now
so your choice do you wish to sink the
growth of the world economy
which by the way is what allows people
to live longer it allows people to be
healthy it allows people to care about
the environment because i'll tell you
what you don't care about when you are
living in abject poverty burning dung
for fuel global warming that's not
something that's on the top 1 million of
your of your issues
but for the very rich among us these are
the top issues the top issues are
great systems how can we impact the
great systems of climate by also taking
control of the great systems of
economics
a civilization whose primary worry is
whether there is going to be global
warming over the course of the next 100
years that causes some people to move
from their homes and causes if the
estimates are correct and the economy
continues to grow as it has done for the
past century and a half it will cause
a few thousand deaths over the course of
a century
i really this is according to the
estimates from bjorn lombard over at the
copenhagen institute and the notion that
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people are going to die from from global
warming is just
based on the fact that human beings
adapt it to their environment and adapt
to the climate that's not true
the notion that you're going to sink the
world economy on that basis
that is a um that is a rich people thing
and there's a reason that this is a rich
people conference
everybody's taking private jets to these
climate change conferences because if
you don't live in a rich country this is
not a major concern to you your first
concern is how do i make sure that my
kids live through the next year not what
is the climate going to be like in a
hundred years
and so if we who are looking long-term
wish to protect the human species from
whatever the
vacillations and and vicissitudes of
climate
fall upon us we ought to be looking at
things like building sea walls maybe geo
engineering
maybe painting the roads right there
there are things that we can do
that are designed to mitigate the
effects of climate change human beings
are really good at adaptation we really
really suck at completely changing
entire systems of how we live in order
to prevent long off
costs that we still don't know
will materialize in the way that the u.n
keeps saying they will materialize okay
but this means that every climate summit
is hailed by our brilliant media as as
the turning point for civilization
according to cbs news president joe
biden rejoined the paris agreement on
his first day in office but senate
democrats are still fighting over new
climate legislation that would give mr
biden something to brag about as the u.s
attempts to reassert itself as a leader
at next week's global climate summit let
me just tell you something i don't care
whether the european cs is a leader
we are the leaders and they're just
gonna have to deal with it and the fact
is that europe is a dying continent it's
been a dying continent for quite a long
time if we wish to follow europe down
the primrose path we can but to pretend
that we are subject to the moral the
moral whim of a continent responsible
for two world wars
responsible not only for those world
wars but for a
a lack of growth a a spineless embrace
of
a
of an innervated future and like what
makes us subject to the europeans
they've been hanging on our coattails
for well over a century at this point
and why exactly would i care what the
french think
about our climate policy considering
again
that the the united states
is actually reducing its climate
emissions and by the way is the basis
for all global growth in the economy
like why why would that make a
difference to me
there's a great book out right now by
david harsanya it's called the euro
trash
all about the the problems in the
european union and there's a whole group
of people in the united states who sort
of love europe but refuse to see any of
the downsides of europe like for example
the fact that a huge percentage of their
population sits home and gets paid by
the government to do nothing
like for example the fact that they have
no growth rates
like for example as we'll get to the
fact that there are no children in
europe
so why why are we taking our cues from
europe exactly but i love the
assumptions in the media we have to have
joe biden a decrepit old man
wander over to europe in order to
provide a moral example to the europeans
reassert ourselves as a leader
come on
the countries that adopted the paris
agreement in 2015 now nearly every
country in the world except iran iraq
and turkey are to meet every five years
to update their ambitions the summit was
delayed last year because of the
pandemic i love what they update their
ambitions because remember the paris
records were not binding the paris
accord said
we are going to try to do x in five
years we're going to try to lower our
emissions by this percentage in 10 years
okay so people get together and they
make a pinky swear
that they're going to lower their
emissions and most of the time they
don't hit any of those targets but they
all feel real good about themselves and
the media talk about how we have finally
achieved world peace
this year the goal is to prove that
countries take the priority seriously
and are working on issues such as
methane emission reduction enacting a
global carbon market and weaning
countries off coal production the action
of the us delegation are under a
microscope oh really what are they going
to do about it
seriously america is historically the
world's leading emitter of greenhouse
gases and still the world's leading
producer of fossil fuels however mr
biden and senate democrats are
deadlocked trying to negotiate a deal
that would invest hundreds of billions
in climate policies
west virginia senator joe manchin has
opposed the price of the package a clean
electricity performance program and a
carbon tax data show that without those
policies the us will fail to meet their
goal of lower emissions and therefore
global temperatures okay by the way the
united states could go to zero emissions
tomorrow the climate the change in the
in the climate trajectory would be a
fraction of a degree celsius over the
course of the next century this ain't
just about the united states china is by
far the world's leading emitter india is
emitting like crazy developing countries
emit as they develop
before the paris agreement the global
economy was on track to by the year 2100
warm the planet at least 3.7 degrees
celsius above 1900 pre-industrial levels
and not today 1900 right today existing
policies will lead to a 2.9 degree
increase and announced targets would
than the increase to 2.4 degrees still
hotter than the paris agreement's
objective of less than two degrees
warmer but william nordhaus noble
prize-winning economist he says why are
we even aiming for 1.5 degrees celsius
change the costs of that economically
speaking are actually higher than if we
let that amount of change happen
the agreement has three main pillars
that will be in focus at the summit
so-called nationally determined
contributions are the targets countries
set for lowering emissions the goals are
not legally binding
a second pillar is international climate
financing mr biden announced in april he
would double usaid sent to help
developing countries to help them adapt
to a green economy and avoid
climate-related devastation
mr biden doubled that commitment again
last month a promise of 11.4 billion
dollars in need of congressional
approval by the way those countries are
saying no no we don't need 11.4 billion
we need like 70 billion a year we need
like trillions of dollars which of
course is true the third pillar is borne
by climate envoy drone car
kerry's been traveling the world for the
past 10 months meeting with world
leaders on the climate crisis vocalizing
america's commitment to the issue
pressuring others to do the same
domestically kerry has worked with the
private sector to get corporations to
agree to lowering their emissions which
could bolster america's reputation ooh
our reputation man i'm what will the
germans who are shipping in russian oil
at this very moment i can't
man if we don't have the moral approval
of the germans i don't know what i'll do
i i feel like doc holliday in tombstow
ike if i thought you weren't my friend
i don't know what i'd like who cares
like seriously who cares what the
europeans think
who cares
it it's so irritating hey so
the un
is now also attempting to push the so
the un which which can't control
anything of note around the world the un
is a garbage organization filled with
garbage countries and the u.n
which cannot stop
full-scale atrocities happening across
the globe can't stop chinese enslavement
if the uyghurs can't stop massacres and
myanmar can't stop anything
but they can preach to us about climate
change
they can do so using a cartoon dinosaur
not barney which would at least be
amusing no they actually created a
computer-generated dinosaur to lecture
us about climate change now call me
crazy but i don't take my climate change
advice from a cartoon in extinct species
i just don't
and i certainly don't take my advice
from something far worse the united
nations which is the most isolate of
international politics a hive of scum
and villainy
nonetheless here is the u.n pushing the
climate change agenda
listen up people
you're headed for a climate disaster and
yet every year governments spend
hundreds of billions of public funds on
fossil fuel subsidies
imagine if we had spent hundreds of
billions per year subsidizing giant
meteors that's what you're doing right
now
around the world people are living in
poverty
don't you think helping them would make
more sense than i don't know paying for
the demise of your entire species
okay i love the the false binary here
drawn by the u.n like what idiot
produced this the people living in
poverty you think they care deeply about
the climate change policies is this like
their number one as i point out the
great escape from poverty is generally
based on carbon-based fuels
and by the way the notion that if you
send foreign aid to to impoverished
countries that the usual dictators and
and thugs who run impoverished countries
because there's a high correlation
between horrible governance and
impoverishment that those people just
take that foreign aid and they hand it
out to the people
ugh the un un but these are the we need
their moral imprimatur and we also need
the moral and premature of the children
of course this is very important
right so we have climate activists who
are currently sitting outside at the
white house starving themselves uh it is
uh they are on a hunger strike
they they're
if you can't see this there's a bunch of
people they're now sitting in in
wheelchairs uh because they've so
weakened themselves
in striking
against the sun and um and they're
holding signs that say things like
hunger striking for a good job
well if you were hungry striking for a
good job you could you know like eat and
then go get one considering there are 10
million open jobs this one says hunger
striking for my future children we'll
get to that in a second about how we are
a civilization that is dying because we
100 are and then one person has a sign
that says hunger striking for my
community
i feel like you could do better things
than not eating for your community
anyway here is uh here's one of these
activists talking about this
when there's a big flood when that
finally comes or the big hurricane or
the
the catastrophe that we can't totally
see coming yet like where is our family
gonna meet up
i don't ever want to have conversations
like that
okay and then it says one activist was
hospitalized because of the strike they
are all now using wheelchairs to keep
steady that future where we we don't
ever have to have a family meeting place
where i can just live
i can be with my future wife and my kids
and have that garden that means
everything to me
and i'm willing to do everything
for it to be real
uh i have a question who's preventing
you from uh from having like a house and
a life or anything remotely like that
okay so jen saki then pay tribute to
this because this administration has yet
to find a radical activist that won't
support
the president admires the activism the
energy the um
of of young people who are out there
advocating for what they believe in and
the changes that he agree should be made
to
how society functions to
long overdue investments in our climate
okay so
i have a question as a society what are
our priorities
really what are our priorities
because what i'm finding from this
administration and from a huge
percentage of the american population is
that our priorities don't line up with
reality that they they spit directly in
the face of reality actually the
realities of climate change are pretty
obvious the climate is changing a large
part of that is human caused
i'm fully willing to accept the
conclusions of the international into
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change the ipcc
all of that can be said and still the
mitigation and adaptation measures that
they are recommending can be fully
idiotic in every respect
hey the exaggerations by the media can
be fully idiotic in every respect but
again the reason this is a top priority
for people is because it distracts them
from the underlying realities which are
that you need resources in order to
maintain life on this planet you need to
actually allow civilizations to grow
and human adaptation is a better
strategy than undermining the key
institutions of the society but perhaps
that's the point perhaps the point is
the undermining of the key institutions
of our society i can think of no other
reason for why we seem to be pursuing as
a civilization all these policies at
once policies that undermine basic
institutions and the free market economy
which has produced
unprecedented prosperity in human
history if you look at the growth of per
capita gdp on planet earth up till about
1800 it's essentially kind of flat
for thousands of years
and maybe it grows a little bit it kind
of goes it's got it's completely flat
for hundreds of thousands of years then
it starts to increase
a little bit and then you hit about 1800
and suddenly it goes exponential that is
because of free markets it's because of
trade it's because of technology and
innovation it's because risk taking and
now we're seeking to undermine all of
those things in the name of what our
inability to adapt to a climate that
we've been adapting to for literally the
entirety of the human species
it's the institution of free markets has
to go and of course the institutions of
parenting have to go that's very
important
because school boards need to control
your kids
and of course
institutions that are most basic to
humanity things like biological sex
those have to go to all the institutions
associated with biological sex have to
go we'll get to that in a second because
the state department has some very very
stringent priorities the priorities are
abandoning women to the taliban in
afghanistan and making sure that if
you're a non-gender
if you're a gender non-binary person you
can put an x on your passport we'll get
to that in just one moment first let's
talk about your sleep quality so i will
admit lately i've not been getting
enough sleep i'm going to bed too late
waking up too early but when i get on
that bed i better be asleep inside the
next five minutes because i know my kids
are gonna wake me up any second this is
why i treasure my helix sleep mattress
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you're
matched to the mattress comes shipped
directly to your door for free you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again 10 year warranty try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you're
going to because it's made just for you
just go to hellosleep.com take their two
minutes sleep quiz they will match you
to a customized mattress that'll give
you the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders plus two free pillows for our
listeners at
go helixsleep.com them out right now
okay
we'll get to the suicidal nature of our
civilization in just one second you know
some light-hearted stuff first the daily
wire has had an unbelievable year so so
far and we thank you for that we need
your help to continue that momentum it
allows us to do things like signing for
example alison williams who was booted
from espn for the great sin of not
taking the vaccine because she already
had natural immunity and she wanted to
get pregnant we hired her to do sports
coverage for us okay we need your help
to do stuff like that it's really really
important not just to bring you great
content but to push back against leftist
domination of our institutional culture
here at the daily wireless leads do not
dictate our content you do you decide
what to watch which creators to support
if you want premium entertainment and
sports content without the woke become a
member at dailywire.com subscribe use
code do not comply at checkout for 25
off we're building a movement against
the leftist hollywood machine andrew
biden's unconstitutional mandate we need
your help go to dailywire.com subscribe
code do not comply for 25 off join the
fight
also if you've not yet checked out
morning wire you really need to it's
great not only has our daily news show
been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its release it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth it's like 15 minutes all the
news you need to know and while we are
working overtime to bring you that news
we need your help to keep the facts
trending toward number one so please
subscribe start listening down to
morningwire on apple spotify wherever
you listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so the priorities of this
government are very very screwed up and
the priorities of our civilization are
very screwed up so we're prioritizing
cracking down on parents at school
boards we are prioritizing climate
change meanwhile the gdp growth in the
united states in the third quarter was a
two percent annualized growth that was
just reported this morning that's a
garbage rate of growth it is a garbage
rate of growth and it is created by bad
government policy and that's a choice it
is a choice whether to innovate the
american public i've been saying for for
months at this point that basically the
biden administration is offering the
american public a choice do you whisk
wish to be a risk seeking adventurous
people or do you wish to climb in the
bathtub with a box of cheetos and just
die because that seems to be the path
our civilization is interested in taking
when you concern yourself not only with
silliness but with fundamentally
undermining the keys to growth okay in
order to grow in reality you actually
have to recognize that reality exists
and then work within its confines you
have to work with the tools god gave you
okay one of those tools by the way in
terms of like let's take the most
baseline level okay in order for you to
grow as a society you have to have
babies
and this seems like pretty obvious there
have to be enough kids in the next
generation
even especially if you have social
welfare programs right you have to have
kids who are going to support grandpa
and grandma somebody's got to pay the
bill especially when you're taking out
trillions of dollars in debt well we are
currently in this country not doing that
we are not having babies no one in the
west is having babies by the way that's
not unique to the united states right
now the united states has a fertility
rate of about 1.7 kids per family that
is not replacement rates that means the
population of the united states declines
unless you bring in immigrants which is
what the united states has been doing
for quite a while
and again
not rare
okay the fact is that if you look at the
fertility rates across a wide variety of
western countries there's literally not
a western country
a european country outside of georgia
like the country of georgia
that has fertility rates above two
right the only other quote unquote
western country and it's not quite
western because in the middle east
israel has fertility rates above two
every other western country european
country america all of them have
fertility rates below the below two
which means they are not reproducing at
replacement rates
okay when you don't reproduce it is very
difficult to see how your civilization
has a future just materially speaking
it's very difficult to see how that's
the case france has a fertility rate of
1.86
iceland 1.74 sweden 1.71 ireland 1.7
denmark 1.7 when you get to the bottom
of the list you're looking at italy
which has a replacement rate of 1.27
fertility rate of 1.27 that means that
their population is going to halve over
the course of the next couple of
generations
for greece it's true for finland it's
like every country in the west is now
not reproducing
instead we are focused on how do we
basically live out our last days as a
civilization in comfort and one of the
ways that we live our days as a
civilization and comfort is by lying to
ourselves about fulfillment being found
not in building
but in being right fulfillments is not
is not found in in having a mission
or promulgating good values fulfillments
is found in naval gazing which is why
the state department
has now decided it's very important that
we issue the first third gender passport
for non-binary intersex and gender
non-conforming americans now you might
think to yourself wait a second
it is one thing for you to write on a
college essay that you are non-gender
conforming or that you are non-gender
binary or some nonsense
right it's one thing to write that in in
your in your little facebook profile
it's another thing for a governmental
document which specifically designated
in order to help determine who you are
to have you put that because that's a
subjective metric right
it's like saying i've it's like
putting on your passport that you're a
bon jovi fan like there's no way to tell
whether that's true or not
nor is it relevant your interior
feelings have no relevance to the
question of how the government ought to
identify you for purposes of knowing who
the hell's in the country
but the state department now feels it's
very important for you to look at your
passport and feel that your passport
reflects your innermost feelings or
society that now treasures the inner
subjectivity of feelings over
the identification within reality
according to abc news four months after
announcing it would allow a third gender
option for us citizens on their
passports the state department said
wednesday it has issued one it's the
first of its kind denoted with an x for
non-binary intersex and gender
non-conforming u.s citizens the
recipient is colorado resident dana
the reason i pronounce it that way is
because the last name is spelled
z-z-y-y-m
i have doubts that uh this is the
original last name of this person
associate director of the intersex
campaign for equality and a client of
lambda legal
i almost burst into tears when i opened
the envelope pulled out my new passport
and saw the x stamped boldly under sex
i'm also ecstatic that other intersex
non-binary u.s citizens will soon be
able to apply for passports with the
correct gender marker it took six years
but to have an accurate passport one
that doesn't force me to identify as
male or female but recognizes i am
neither is liberating
said in a statement
the agency is still preparing to make
the option widely available for
passports and other documents such as
the consular report of birth abroad so
it's not just for americans by the way
it's people who are green card holders
hold their u.s passport pretty much
anybody trying to get in the country
i want to reiterate on the occasion of
this passport issuance the state
department's commitments promoting the
freedom dignity and equality of all
people including lgbt
lgbtqi plus persons said state
department spokesperson ned price in a
statement
it just uh the heroism the heroism
right we're just going to ignore the
objective reality or what id is supposed
to do so that you feel better about
yourself
the state department meanwhile is saying
that they're pursuing an end to
gender-based discrimination with
policies like this i mean not
gender-based discrimination in
afghanistan where women are literally
forced into bags and then into the
basement but gender discrimination like
you know for example being asked to say
whether you are biologically male or
female on a passport
president biden and secretary blinken
have made clear it is the policy of the
united states to pursue an end to
violence and discrimination on the basis
of gender of sexual orientation gender
identity or expression or sex
characteristics the department of state
is committed to promoting the freedom
the dignity and equality of all persons
including of course intersex persons
hmm so the very important stuff
now is this again is this the mark of a
civilization that is on the decline or
the mark of a civilization that is on
the mend and ready to grow
and if you're worried about people
getting married having babies a basic
basic thing that is necessary is
understanding that men and women exist
that sexual dichotomy exists in mammals
if you refuse to even acknowledge this
it makes it a lot more difficult to
convince people that it's important to
get together and have kids in stable
families
but we as a civilization have decided to
abandon that on behalf of higher falutin
ideals like can we make sure that no
carbon ever enters the atmosphere or at
least pretend to
right we have to make sure that gender
fluidity is prized above the survival of
civilization right these are these are
things that matter
and to pretend that they're not in
conflict is very silly a civilization
that embraces fiction about the nature
of biological sex is a civilization that
is doomed to move away from reality
a civilization that rejects truth on
behalf of sensitivity is a civilization
that cannot exist for very long in the
real world reality always has its
revenge
it takes just one indicator really
interesting piece by susie weiss over at
barry weiss's sub stack susie is barry's
sister
it's called first cum's love then comes
sterilization
rachel diamond looks like most of the
moms the park slope cafe where we meet
she's wearing a green t-shirt under a
black corduroy jumper sensible shoes
carries a smart leather bag she sips a
four dollar iced chai except the 31 year
old isn't a mom and she never will be
you know diamond says shirley i never
expected to be the poster child of
sterilization on the aspiring actress
tiktok one finds short funny videos
about diamond's job working the register
at a cafe near union square and updates
on her rescue pitbull roo who has anemia
mixed in our clips extolling her child
free life they have titles like
sterilization attempt number three and
being child free we do know what we're
missing
it's been five months since she had her
fallopian tubes cut not tied and she has
64 000 followers
growing up near hershey pennsylvania
time and always assumed she'd have a
family of her own then came college at
arcadia university her political
awakening away from her conservative
roots and toward progressivism and a
therapist who she then found online a
few months after graduation who made her
realize that being spent as a child was
deeply traumatic and that made
and that it made her fear authority
figures like her father she decided she
never wanted to be one herself never
ever ever
looking back i never pretended my
american girl dolls were children they
were always my sister she said there
were little things showing that i wasn't
preparing myself for motherhood i think
for me it's as innate as saying i've
always wanted to be a mom
diamond is hardly an outlier says susie
weiss americans are making fewer babies
than we've made since we started keeping
track in the 1930s some women like
diamond are not just putting off
pregnancy they're eliminating the
possibility of it all together last year
the number of deaths exceeded that of
births in 25 states up from five the
year before the marriage rate is at an
all-time low 6.5 marriages per 1000
people millennials are the first
generation where a majority are
unmarried about 56 percent they're also
more likely to live with their parents
than previous generations were in their
20s and 30s they also aren't having sex
the number of young men ages 18 to 30
who admit they've had no sex in the past
year tripled between 2008 and 2018.
cities like new york where secular young
americans flocked to build their lives
are increasingly childless in san
francisco there are more dogs than
children
any of this speak of a civilization in
growth mode
it used to be says susie weiss that
people wanted to make babies women
especially but also men
that was a healthy young person's
default position our existence depended
on it we wanted to do other things of
course the great post-feminist challenge
was how to have it all but for an
increasing number the question now isn't
how to have it all it's why do it at all
this psychological reversal didn't just
happen it took place inside the
hurricane of spiritual cultural
environmental forces swirling around us
but the message from this young cohort
is clear life is exhausting enough and
the world is broken and burning who
would want to bring new innocent life
into a criminally unequal society
situated on a planet with
catastrophically rising sea levels
according to a new poll 39 percent of
gen zeus are hesitant to procreate for
fear of the climate apocalypse which is
just insane guys i'm sorry you're crazy
a nationally representative study of
adults in michigan found over a quarter
of adults are child free by choice
so basically we have decided that all
the hallmarks of being an adult all the
hallmarks of adjusting to reality and
building a civilization have been thrown
over in favor of a false pursuit of
gender identity
and hedonism that that's essentially the
trade the trade is you get to have a
good time in the moment and feel morally
self-righteous as your civilization dies
by the way there are other civilizations
out there
so you can pretend that our civilization
dying is somehow a good thing because of
all of our historic excesses and all the
problems with our civilization just
understand there are other people out
there who are waiting to take over and
they are far far worse than our
civilization in virtually every way
but our civilization is now
socially suicidal and this has massive
consequences for the future
it means that the economy slows for
example it means there's no one there to
pay the bills it means
that
on foreign policy more people suffer
broadly speaking it means the growth
rates globally come to an end
it means that all the nice things that
you think are natural to life start to
collapse because when institutions that
create it those things collapse so do
the things
virtually every westernized instit
every western country is now
experiencing massive drops in births
it's happening pretty much everywhere
according to pew research
in italy japan france belgium they're
among the nations that have reported
sudden drops in births about nine months
after the start of the pandemic compared
with the previous year some worry that a
baby bust will create societal age
imbalances and strain healthcare and
retirement systems while also eventually
stripping the economy of young workers
who tend to drive innovation and growth
meanwhile
you can tell by the way that these are
these been dying civilizations for a
while considering how many kids are now
being born out of wedlock
one of the fundamental institutions of
society is marriage why because it it
civil is it civilizes men marriage was
designed to civilize men it was designed
to allow women to grow up in intact
to allow children to grow up in intact
homes and therefore have healthy lives
and then become productive members of
civilization themselves
marriage was a civilizing institution we
dumped it we decided that personal
self-fulfillment was much more important
than giving a kid an actual life with
two parents who care about them
yes of opposite sexes because a child
does need a mother and a child doesn't
need a father
right now the share of live births
outside marriage
in the united states
it's 70 in the black community it's 40
in the white community
it's true abroad
in france 60.4 percent of kids are born
outside marriage this is as of 2018. in
sweden it's 54.5 in denmark it's 54
if you think that has no relationship
with the number of people who are on
social assistance you're on your mind
if you think there's a healthy way for a
society grow you're crazy but that's
maybe this is a society with a death
wish
maybe this is a society that has decided
to sacrifice truth logic and decency in
favor of the notion that we are bad and
we deserve to go this way
right after all we are a scourge on the
earth
i think there is a strong reason why
when you look at the actual reproduction
rates in the united states they are
heavily associated with religion they
are striated by religion
right now the only people reproducing
above replacement rates in the united
states
are people who are religious
period end of story
i mean i'm looking at the rates right
now the fertility rates in the united
states by religion among catholics
2.3 among mormons 3.4 these are above
replacement rates among jews 2.0 and
among orthodox used like four
among protestants evangelical
protestants it's 2.3
and then among atheists 1.6 agnostics
1.3
the as as society becomes more secular
as a society decides that future that
the future doesn't matter and starts to
undermine its own institutions
and starts to embrace fictional nonsense
on behalf of the subjective feelings of
a view the society begins to crumble
it also leads to absurdities like this
story from bbc news
quote i've had someone saying they would
rather kill me than hitler says 24 year
old jenny they said they would strangle
me with a belt if they were in a room
with me and hitler that was so bizarrely
violent just because i won't have sex
with trans women jenny is a lesbian
woman she says she is only attracted to
women who are biologically female and
have vaginas she therefore only has sex
and relationships with women who are
biologically female jenny doesn't think
this should be controversial but not
everyone agrees she has been described
as transphobic a genital fetishist a
pervert and a turf a trans-exclusionary
radical feminist
jenny who lives in london says there's a
common argument they try and use that
goes what if you met a woman in a bar
and she's really beautiful and you got
on really well and you went home and you
discovered she had a penis would you
just not be interested yes because if
someone seems sexually attractive at
first you can go off them i just don't
possess the capacity to be sexually
attracted to people who are biologically
male regardless of how they identify
according to carolyn laubridge over at
bbc news
i became aware of this particular issue
after i wrote an article about sex lies
and legal consent several people got in
touch with me to say there was a huge
problem for lesbians who are being
pressured to accept the idea that a
penis can be a female sex organ
i knew this would be a hugely divisive
subject but i wanted to find out how
widespread the issue was ultimately it
has been difficult to determine the true
scale of the problem because there's
been little research on the topic only
one survey to my knowledge however those
effective have told me the pressure
comes from a minority of trans women as
well as activists or not necessarily
trans themselves
so apparently this is now a major issue
among lesbians is that because of the
stupidity of suggesting
gender fluidity
lesbians are being told that they must
have sex with biological men
because if they don't have sex with
biological men this means that they are
apparently straight because some
biological men are women
and the illogic has no bounds there are
no limits to it none
and so as a civilization would we like
to die or is a civilization going to
embrace basic truths that undergird
institutions that allow for growth
those are the choices before us it's
pretty obvious there's a whole group of
people in politics who are opting for
the former rather than the latter that
they are opting for a civilization in
decline because at least we'll have a
good time on our way out because at
least we will feel justified morally in
overturning these structural oppressions
of reality because reality is full of
structural oppression reality is full of
inequality reality is full of
difficulties so if we just ignore those
difficulties if we struck restructure
society around the idea that we can get
rid entirely of reality
then we can put off the nightmares
we can put off having to adjust to
civilization civilization
and then you know later if the
civilization falls apart you know i'm
pretty sure well you know we did our
best at least we did the moral thing at
least we did the moral thing all right
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
wiedowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show